what do you think most people get wrong
about motivation
they think it's a permanent fix
they think it's something that
that is
a constant
they think that maybe once I get it I'm
gonna hold on to it
and that's the thing about that I was
telling you I always talk about
it's nothing is permanent
nothing is permanent and a lot of times
you have to learn to perform without
motivation
purpose you have to learn to perform a
lot of different things and that's what
people think they think I need to have
this motivation
to work out to study to be better so if
they don't have it they just don't
do it
and that's where you fail
you have to learn to train your mind
well beyond motivation if you have
motivation that's great that's some can
lean to the fire all it takes is a
little bit of spark you can burn
the whole Force up
but
motivation you get to learn to exist
without it you have to learn to be you
have to be your best self and your least
motivated
and that's the tricky part about all
that motivation is just a word you
have to have these different things in
your mind on where you want to go and
know that motivation is not going to get
me there
because I'm not going to always be
motivated Jacob said the exact same
thing you said that discipline needs
motivation for breakfast
and discipline is good too
but without a clear headspace there's no
discipline what do you mean
so let's say we have a circuit breaker
okay and I'm loading everything up to
one circuit just load it up
it's gonna blow
and once that thing blows man the circus
all up
you gotta have
each thing plugged into the right spot
like a crowded garage
you can't put anything in it once your
brain is crowded discipline is great
motivation is great but if you can't fit
in your brain because it's all
cluttered with
there's no discipline
you may have it sometimes when it fits
in that crowded garage of your mind but
you don't have the consistency that you
need to have with your discipline so
what are you talking about here are you
saying doing self work and reflecting on
you as an individual are you doing
therapy I call it my I call it mental
zones I don't get in too much because
it'd be here all day
but basically
is you're organized in your mind so you
can put that discipline
so a lot of people talk about discipline
okay great why do you fall off the
wagon why can't I continue with
this routine going to the gym being
better waking up early eating the right
Foods
is because maybe it's your kids maybe
it's your wife maybe it's your job and
it's all just stuffed in your
brain you don't have it
compartmentalized and organized in these
nice shelves like you look in the garage
it's all a nice organized
militant garage hey where are my
dumbbells right there
a lot of people whose brain Hey where's
my demos uh let me look they're
throwing they're looking through
toads they're all up
so where am I gonna put discipline in
that mind if I can't find other you
gotta be able to find all these
different things in your mind oh I can
put discipline right there
I can put consistency right there I can
put all these things right there in that
spot so that's what I'm talking about if
your life is not organized
in your life being
everything around you
because it takes one little up
piece of an outside interference to cut
it your whole mind
because it's on such a knife edge that's
right and people don't get that your
mind has to always be clear that's why
that's why I meditate two hours every
single night
because I refresh I reorganize the
garage which is my mind every night
so then disciplines in there
organization everything is in this right
spot so if I wake up I'm ready to go
this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't I've replaced
my morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all 8 flavors with your
first box that's drink lmnt.com
wisdom thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that clip with Goggins
then press here for the full episode in
all of its glory and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]